Hey Thoughty2 here.
In the southwest of China's Sichuan province
sits a small village called Atuleer.
Where the local schoolchildren must climb
an 800 metre bamboo ladder up the side of
a sheer cliff face, just to get to school.
The only school for many miles around sits
atop this rocky outcrop, there are no roads
or pathways to the top, only this ladder.
I bet your journey to school seems incredibly
benign in comparison.
You may not have to scale a cliff face to
attend school, but the education you receive
every day, or did once receive is just as
precarious and insufficient.
Education is broken.
Over the past 50 years the world has changed
beyond recognition, yet the school systems,
in most countries have stayed static.
Our current education systems were designed
and built in the industrial age, in some countries
that's as long ago as the 18th century.
Sure there have been many subtle changes over
the decades but the basic goal of our school
systems has remained exactly the same for
over 200 years.
And what is that goal?
To produce obedient factory workers.
During the industrial era and right up to
the epoch of the 21st century, most people
worked in manufacturing, either on production
lines, on farms or in mines.
Where things like creativity and individuality
only get in the way of profits.
Factory owners needed obedient drones in large
numbers and so many wealthy business owners
invested large sums of money into lobbying,
to influence politicians to shape the school
systems in the ideologies of said factory
owners.
Putting values such as order and discipline
as top priority and making sure that creativity
and individualism were quashed.
Such lobbying happened mostly in America but
nevertheless, the school systems in most developed
countries today are still built on the same
robotic and stale ideologies.
And so kids today arrive at school nice and
early, not a minute too late.
We are ordered to sit down in our pre-designated
seats, because god only knows what utter chaos
would unravel if we were to sit where we pleased.
We are programmed to respond to a series of
bells and whistles that signify when we are
allowed to eat and leave.
We have to ask permission to speak, to move,
to go to the bathroom.
This used to be kind of okay, because this
forced obedience would carry over to the factory
floor, which is where most people ended up,
right after school.
But today, and for quite some time now, we
have been living in a world where most people
can do whatever they desire for a career if
they try hard enough.
I mean you can actually be a professional
bed warmer, a pet food taster or a Ravenmaster,
yes these are all real jobs.
The nature of jobs has changed drastically
and today we live in a world where qualities
such as creativity, individualism and entrepreneurialism
are highly sought after by a lot of employers.
Let me ask you a question, how come, if you're
bad at English, Maths or Science you're repeatedly
told "you're not trying hard enough".
Your work is scrutinised, your parents are
notified of your "poor performance", you're
made to re-sit tests until you get it right.
Yet if you're bad at art, music or sport you're
simply told "don't worry, it's just not you're
thing" despite these all being entirely valid
career choices.
The huge fact of life that modern school systems
ignore is that everyone has their own unique
talents and things they are really passionate
about.
We're all naturally good at something and
terrible at other things, whether that's because
of our genetics or upbringing.
Some children are more creative whilst others
are more academic; we're all unique.
Albert Einstein supposedly wrote "Everybody
is a genius.
But if you judge a fish by its ability to
climb a tree, it will live its whole life
believing that it is stupid."
The human brain's ability and desire to learn
is astonishing.
And yes it is possible for almost anyone to
learn anything, I'm not saying that every
child shouldn't learn mathematics because
every child can.
But where most school systems fail is in bringing
out the best in every child and encouraging
exploration of their natural abilities.
But the really stupid thing is that schools
don't even do a decent job of teaching English,
Maths and Science, in fact they do a rather
terrible job indeed.
Public education today is based on a system
of taking a bunch of information and systematically
reciting that information to the students.
Whom are later tested on their ability to
remember this information.
And the key point here is that exams only
test a child's ability to remember.
So weeks before your exam you would recite
the same textbook information over and over
again until you had near enough, the entire
textbook memorised.
But what happens after the exam?
You forget it all.
Multiple studies have shown that children
and adults forget 95% of everything they learn
via memorisation, after just three days.
So an A* test score says no more about a child
than their ability to recite information,
it is not a strongly correlated representation
of actual intelligence, that is the ability
to acquire new skills by one's own accord.
This process of faux learning via memorisation
is known as inauthentic learning, because
you aren't actually learning, only regurgitating
information.
Anyone can do that, it's what I do for a living.
So you ask, how does one learn authentically?
How do we actually teach kids instead of asking
them to memorise?
Well, we quite simply have to spark their
curiosity.
Humans are unquenchably curious, as toddlers
we have to touch everything we see, stick
our fingers in plug sockets and dismantle
everything.
That curiosity never leaves us, it's hopefully
why you watch my videos.
When you allow children to become curious
about something they will actually teach themselves
because they have a primal desire to find
out as much as they can.
And the best part is that this self-curiosity-driven
learning is completely authentic and children
will absorb that knowledge like a sponge and
most importantly, you can be sure they will
remember it, because when we are engaged we
are happy and our brains naturally remember
the times when we are happy.
A great number of the world's greatest thinkers,
its greatest entrepreneurs and history's greatest
leaders all share something in common, they
dropped out of school.
Names such as Richard Branson, Quentin Tarantino,
Mark Zuckerberg, Steve Jobs, Bill Gates, F.
Scott Fitzgerald, John Lennon, Walt Disney,
Tom Hanks, Coco Chanel, Benjamin Franklin,
Albert Einstein, Charles Dickens and Princess
Diana.
Every single one of these successful and highly
influential individuals dropped out of school
between the ages of 11 and 16.
Now, I'm not promoting dropping out of school,
but illustrating a quality that all these
people have in common, they were incredibly
passionate and curious about one particular
thing.
Do you really think they would have dropped
out of education if their school supported
their true passion?
No, these people all felt the same way, as
many young people do today, that school was
only holding them back, slowing them down.
Luckily these people were able to follow their
passions regardless of their education, but
sadly, millions of children aren't.
Many young people could unlock their true
passions if the education industry focused
on what they do best instead of everything
they're not good at.
But thankfully, today you can fulfil your
own curiosity.
Thanks to technology we are now able to learn
anything we desire, with unlimited invaluable
information at our fingertips.
Self-education and discovery sites such as
Skillshare enable you to fulfil your thirst
for becoming a better you, where traditional
education has failed you.
Skillshare is an online learning platform
with more than 17,000 classes in design, photo
and more.
I didn't go to university I instead used the
incredible resources available on the internet
to teach myself the skills I needed to do
what I love.
And by doing so I am have been able to fulfil
my passion of making videos and teaching others
about incredible things.
YouTube is my career and I'm so very grateful
that today we don't have to rely on outdated
traditional education systems to follow our
passions.
Using Skillshare you can follow your passions
and turn doing whatever it is you love doing,
into a career.
A premium Skillshare membership gives you
unlimited access to thousands of classes from
leading experts all around the world.
So you can learn from the very best, and unlock
your true potential, in the comfort of your
own home.
If you have a passion that you would love
to turn into a career, then incredible Skillshare
courses such as "Art of the Start: Turning
Ideas into High-Growth Businesses" are a great
place to start.
Or, say your passion is photography, you can
dive right into a course such as "Going Pro
with Portrait Photography: How to Turn Your
Photography Hobby into a Job" to sharpen up
your skills by learning from a real professional
and discover how to become a pro yourself.
Since Skillshare is sponsoring this video,
the first 500 people to use the promo link
in the description will get their first 2
months, completely free to try it out, risk-free.
After 2 months it's only $10 a month to watch
unlimited classes.
But with two months free you have nothing
to lose and you could look back in a years
time when you're hobby has become your career
and be so thankful that you did.
Now, there's another fundamental problem with
school today and it's not to do with what
goes on in the classroom.
I'm talking about sleep.
When you start a job it's generally accepted
that you will turn up at 9am or earlier every
morning and this same time expectation is
put upon school kids all the way from primary
school, to high-school, college and university.
But there's a deep-rooted biological issue
with that, which explains why when I was at
school I spent at least 30% of my lessons
asleep at my desk.
Our bodies are phenomenal time keepers, and
our subconscious is often well aware of the
current time, even if your conscious mind
isn't.
You know how sometimes you wake up exactly
one minute before your alarm clock.
This is because of your body's circadian rhythm.
This is our internal clock and it also determines
when is the best time for us to fall asleep
and to wake up.
But our circadian rhythm varies throughout
our lives.
When we're younger than 10 our bodies want
to wake up as early as possible but it soon
gets later and later throughout adolescence.
Between the ages of 14 and 24 our circadian
rhythm is set at the latest it will ever be
in our lives and our natural desire is to
wake up later in the morning, for example,
after 10am.
There's nothing we can do to fight this urge.
Recent studies have shown that forcing teenage
students to wake up before 7am to attend school
between 8am and 9am plays havoc with our body's
intended sleep cycle.
The result is that teenagers get far less
sleep throughout these critical years and
concentration in the classroom takes a steep
dive into the sleepy abyss.
There is absolutely no scientific evidence
that starting school any earlier than 10 or
11am is beneficial to learning, quite the
opposite in fact.
Thankfully this, at least, is changing.
Over the past couple of years in Britain,
as part of large experiment funded by a London
charity, hundreds of schools across the UK
are being asked to shift their school days
forward an hour or two and asking students
to arrive at 10am instead.
This experiment is still ongoing today but
early indications from this large-scale test
have already shown that school children across
the country are happier, more engaged, learning
more and the rising rates of mental illness
among teenagers, which has been partially
attributed to sleep deprivation, are starting
to plateau.
There is one country that has taken changing
the entire school system into their own hands
and made changes so sweeping that the way
they "do school" is completely unrecognisable
to most of us.
And as a result, this country now has the
most successful school system in the entire
world.
Welcome to Finland.
Over the years multiple studies have ranked
Finland as the most successful and most efficient
school system in the world.
And they rank #2 globally for science and
#3 for reading.
But what does Finland do so differently, to
the US for example, which consistently ranks
down in the mid 30s for efficiency?
America also ranks #33 in science and #17
in reading.
For a start, children in Finland don't even
start school until the age of seven, compared
to the normal age of five, in most countries,
allowing them far more time to just "be children".
And for the first six years of a child's education
in Finland, they are not measured in any way,
it literally doesn't matter how they perform
in class, because seriously, what is the point
in testing a 10 year old when all they really
want to do is paint on walls and lick trees.
In fact there is only one, just one standardised
test during the entirety of a child's education
in Finland, and it's not taken until they're
16 years old.
And that exam isn't even a "test" per se,
it's used to find out which students need
more individual help than the others.
Homework is far less common and they don't
begin to issue homework until students are
well into their teen years.
In fact Finish kids spend the least time on
homework per week than any country in the
world, at an average of just over 2 hours
per week compared to six hours per week for
the average American pupil.
The Finish school day is far shorter than
other countries, they typically start at 9am
and finish school between 1 and 2pm.
Teachers in Finland only work for a maximum
of 4 hours each day and they put aside two
hours each week for professional development,
helping them to be better teachers.
One of the biggest differences between Finish
and American schools is the amount of free-time
students are permitted.
In Finland students get a 15 minute break
after every lesson.
The average daily break time of a Finish school
student is a whopping 75 minutes, compared
to just 27 minutes for an American student.
Recent studies have conclusively shown that
more break time relative to class time, actually
increases test scores and learning, and decreases
mental illness, depression and general bad
behaviour amongst school children.
Quite simply a happy and healthy child is
going to be less bored and more engaged.
So how do Finland do when it comes to encouraging
every child's unique abilities?
Remarkably well actually, Finish school pupils
have 25 lessons a week and nine of these are
arts, crafts, music and sports.
That's almost 40% of lessons.
Also, the national curriculum in Finland is
just a set of broad guidelines, rather than
a strict checklist that has to be adhered
to.
The individual teachers have a lot more power
to tailor their lessons to suit their students.
Children aren't segregated into different
classes depending on their intelligence or
historic test scores.
Classes are kept small but children that need
extra help are given huge amounts of 1-on-1
attention to help get them up to speed and
the results show that the gap between the
worst performing kids and the highest performers
in Finland, is the smallest in the world.
In Finland no child is left behind, but it's
actually true over there, rather than just
an empty political slogan.
In Finland the high school dropout rate of
students is a tiny 0.4%, in America it is
25%, by far one of the highest in the developed
world.
America also has one of the largest gaps between
the tests scores of the rich than the poor
in the world.
But a lot of experts argue that you couldn't
simply take the blueprint for the Finish school
system and implement it overnight in America,
for one major reason, the two countries are
culturally, economically and socially very,
very different.
For a start the cultural differences are enormous,
in the US 22% of the population are religiously
unaffiliated, with just 3% categorising themselves
as atheists.
Whereas in Finland an impressive 60% of the
country are religiously unaffiliated or non-believers
and 22% are atheists.
Almost everyone in Finland is middle class,
they have one of the smallest gaps in the
world between the rich and poor.
This allows for a stable and consistent, publicly
funded school system across the entire country.
Whereas America has the biggest wealth inequality
of any developed country, in the world.
This creates huge problems with balancing
the school system from state to state and
district to district.
In America the gap between the quality of
education in poor areas and wealthy areas
is enormous.
To integrate the Finish system into American
schools, the whole economics of the school
system would have to be turned on its head.
American teachers get paid merit pay, a top
up on their salary if their students perform
well in standardised tests.
Causing teachers to push their students beyond
reasonable levels to achieve higher test scores,
with no regard to whether they are genuinely
learning.
Merit pay does not exist in Finland.
Children in Finland, and most countries for
that matter, can go to school without the
fear of violence.
The statistics show that in the US, 27% of
students have carried a dangerous weapon to
school.
10% have carried a gun to school and 40% have
been in a physical fight whilst at school.
Now I'm not here to endlessly praise Finland
or to point fingers at the American or any
other school system.
But proper education is so, unbelievably important
to society, as it is, quite literally, our
future.
The children of today will be the scientists,
doctors, lawyers and politicians of tomorrow.
Economists predict that improving the education
system in the US would boost the US economy
by $27 trillion, over the next few decades.
Similarly in the UK, economists predict that
there is much room for improvement in our
school system too, and doing so would boost
our economy by £3.6 trillion.
Improving education would mean a better, safer
and more sustainable world for everyone.
Yes, we need to take inspiration from Finland,
but we first need to take inspiration from
their attitude towards society and life.
Thanks for watching.